one thing I said all the time on the
trail was that data is the new oil that
our data is now the most valuable asset
in the world and we are none the wiser
we're not seeing a dime of it yes Andrew
taking that analogy one step further if
you were to imagine that the tech
companies are each like they've each
built their own car with their own
proprietary engine but that car isn't
going to go anywhere
without fuel what's the fuel of the 21st
century it's data right and that data
fuel right now we're just giving it away
for free and powering these tech
companies engines to just make more and
more and more money extract more and
more and more value and I think
something that Americans don't know
about is that tech companies are taking
our data directly that data fuel and
putting it in their car but they're also
going out and buying it they're going
and buying it from gas stations
otherwise known as data brokers or data
resellers and not only are we giving the
fuel directly to the tech companies but
these data brokers and resellers are
selling it to the tech companies at gas
stations and we're not seeing any value
from that either yeah and and this gets
even darker when you realize that these
mammoth tech companies are paying zero
and near zero in taxes very often times
and so the public's really getting
squeezed of value in more ways than one
it's incredible that our leaders are so
behind the times that we're just looking
around saying yeah this is appropriate
it's completely unacceptable what we've
allowed to have it